THANK YOU, STEVE.
MORE IN A MOMENT THERE.
>> Dana: MORE THAN 90 DAYS
AFTER PRESIDENT BIDEN TAPPED
HER AS THE POINT PERSON OT
IMMIGRATION VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS GOES TO EL PASO TOMORROW.
MCALLEN IS THE EPICENTER OF THE
CRISIS.
HERE IS SENATOR TED CRUZ.
>> TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF HOW
FAR THEY ARE, CHICAGO,
ILLINOIS, IS CLOSER TO
WASHINGTON, D.C. THAN EL PASO
IS TO MCALLEN AND SO SHE IS
GOING WHERE THE HEIGHT OF THE
PROBLEM ISN’T.
KAMALA, YOU NEED TO GO TO THE
DONNA TENT FACILITY AND LOOK AT
THE CHILDREN IN CAGES THAT YOU
AND JOE BIDEN PUT THERE IN A
WAY THAT IS ENDANGERING THEIR
SAFETY.
>> Dana: LET’S BRING IN
CONGRESSMAN HENRY CUELLAR.
YOU ARE KEEPING US INFORMED
WHAT’S GOING ON DOWN THERE.
I BELIEVE IT WAS YESTERDAY YOU
HAD A JOINT OP-ED IN THE DALLAS
MORNING NEWS ASKING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO COME AND
VISIT.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS A GOOD
STEP SHE IS GOING?
ARE YOU DISAPPOINTED IT WILL BE
IN EL PASO?
>> YOU KNOW, FIRST OF ALL I’M
GLAD SHE IS GOING DOWN TO THE
BORDER BECAUSE THAT IS PART OF
HER JOB PORTFOLIO, NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, YES, THE EPICENTER
IS DOWN THERE IN LOWER RIO
GRANDE, THE LOWER PART OF MY
DISTRICT DOWN THERE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS THAT
ARE DOWN THERE COMPARED TO EL
PASO, YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GET
A TRUE PICTURE OF WHAT’S
HAPPENING.
YOU GO TO THE DONNA, FACILITY,
YOU GO TO ROMA, TEXAS AND THE
MCALLEN AREA SO YOU CAN GET AN
IDEA.
THAT’S HOW YOU CAN GET AN IDEA
OF WHAT IS HAPPENING DOWN AT
THE BORDER.
IT IS A FIRST STEP.
>> Bill: YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT
THAT.
IF THAT’S THE CASE, WHY GO?
>> WELL, AGAIN SHE IS GOING
DOWN TO THE BORDER.
SHE WILL SAY SHE WILL GO DOWN
TO THE BORDER.
YESTERDAY I GOT A CALL FROM ONE
OF MY BORDER PATROL FRIENDS TO
SAY WHY IS SHE GOING OVER THERE?
WE HAVE 140% HIGHER CROSSINGS
OVER HERE.
THIS IS WHERE THE ACTIVITY IS
AT.
AND I COULDN’T ANSWER HIM WHEN
HE ASKED ME THAT QUESTION.
HE IS DOWN THERE IN THE LOWER
RIO GRANDE.
EVEN IF SHE GOES TO EL PASO,
WHICH IS A FIRST STEP, SHE HAS
TO SPEND TIME WITH LANDOWNERS,
WITH STAKEHOLDERS, WITH CITIES
AND COUNTIES OFFICIALS AND I
HOPE SHE SITS DOWN WITH OUR
BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN IN GREEN
AND IN BLUE.
OUR BORDER PATROL AGENTS SO
THEY DON’T JUST GET A PAT ON
THE BACK BUT THEY ACTUALLY GET
SOME REINFORCEMENT AND SUPPORT
DOWN THERE.
>> Bill: SIR, YOU HAVE BEEN ON
OUR PROGRAM MANY TIMES OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU COMING BACK
TODAY.
YOU EXTENDED AN INVITATION TO
HER FOR MONTHS.
DID YOU EVER HEAR BACK FROM HER?
>> NO, WE DIDN’T.
WE HEARD ABOUT IT FROM THE NEWS
LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE.
IN FACT, I TALKED TO SOME OTHER
TEXAS DEMOCRATS, THEY HAD NO
IDEA UNTIL THEY SAW IT IN THE
NEWS.
SO AGAIN, IT DOESN’T MATTER IF
IT’S A DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN
YOU HAVE TO PAY COURTESY TO THE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS THAT ARE
DOWN THERE AT THE BORDER.
>> Dana: DO YOU THINK YOU MIGHT
GET AN INVITATION TO TRAVEL
ALONG WITH HER?
THAT USUALLY IS CUSTOMARY.
>> THAT IS NOT MY DISTRICT.
I’M AN APPROPRIATIONS MEMBER.
WE STARTED APPROPRIATIONS.
THINGS ARE ADDING TO HELP OUR
BORDER PATROL AGENTS TO WORK
WITH MEXICO AND CENTRAL AMERICA.
I WILL DO MY JOB THERE WHILE
SHE GOES TO EL PASO ABOUT 800
PLUS MILES AWAY FROM THE RIO
GRANDE VALLEY.
>> Bill: I DON’T KNOW WHAT SHE
IS GOING TO SEE THERE.
A TRIP MAY NOT SHOW HER MUCH.
WHY DO YOU THINK THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS WAITED SO
LONG FOR THIS?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA BUT I’M SURE
HER PLANNERS TOLD HER IF YOU
WILL GO DOWN TO THE BORDER, GO
TO SOMETHING THAT IS SAFER TO
GO TO, POLITICALLY SAFER.
IF YOU GO DOWN TO THE LOWER RIO
GRANDE WHERE THE HIGH ACTIVITY
AND YOU ARE THERE WITH KIDS AND
FAMILIES, PROSECUTORIAL
DISCAOETION WHERE PEOPLE ARE
BEING RELEASED.
HIGH NUMBERS OF PEOPLE CROSSING
THE BORDER, YOU KNOW,
POLITICALLY IT’S HARDER TO DO
THAT.
I KNOW THAT.
IT’S PART OF MY DISTRICT.
BUT YOU HAVE TO DO WHAT YOU
HAVE TO DO.
YOU JUST CAN’T JUST GO TO ONE
PLACE.
BUT SHE DOES DO THE CHECK THE
BOX AND GO DOWN TO THE BORDER
BY GOING TO EL PASO.
EL PASO IS A BEAUTIFUL PLACE.
>> Bill: YOU ARE A DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN FROM TEXAS.
YOU HAVE BEEN PLEADING FOR HELP
AND YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT A
POLITICALLY SAFE TRIP ON BEHALF
OF THE VICE PRESIDENT.
IS THAT HOW YOU SEE IT?
>> YES, SIR.
>> Dana: YOU KNOW, THE THING IS
SHE WILL AT LEAST BE ABLE TO
SAY THAT SHE WENT TO A BORDER
TOWN THE WEEK BEFORE PRESIDENT
TRUMP WILL JOIN GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT IN THAT SAME AREA.